In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful. Praise be to God, and peace and
blessings be upon the Messenger of God, his family, his companions, and those who
follow his guidance. Now then, the chapter on the
rising of the sun from the west. In the name of God, and praise be to God, and peace
and blessings be upon the Messenger of God, his family, and all his companions.
Now then,
Imam Bukhari, may God have mercy on him,
mentioned in it the hadith of Abu Hurairah, may God be pleased with him,
that the Messenger of God, may God bless him and grant him peace, said: “
The Hour will not come until the sun rises from the west.
When it rises, the people will see it and all will believe. That will be a time when
faith will not benefit a soul that did not believe
before or did not earn good through its faith.” May
God be pleased with him and with the Messenger of God, may God bless him and grant him peace.
[Music]
The Hour will not
come until the sun rises from the west and the people will all believe that will be a time when two men have spread out their garment between them, so they will not trade it nor fold it. May God bless him and grant him peace. [Music] The Hour will not come until a man has left with the milk of
his she-camel, so he will not drink it. The Hour will not
come until he is at his watering trough, so he will not water his animals. The
Hour will not come until the sun has been raised up.  One of you has food in
his mouth, so he should not eat it. Al-
Bukhari, may God have mercy on him, said
that one of the major signs of the Hour is the rising of the sun from
the west.
May God have mercy on him. The
rising of the sun from the west means that repentance will cease, so
the believer will remain in his faith, the sinner in his sin, and the
disbeliever in his disbelief.
[Music]
This is what the verse indicates: the descent of Jesus will not benefit
Jesus, son of Jesus,
and the first of the unfamiliar signs.
As for the heavenly signs, it is the rising of the sun from the west,
and as for the earthly signs, it is the beast and its emergence.
And the first of the major signs is the rising of the sun from the west, and the earthly signs are the beast and its emergence. And the first of the major signs is the rising of the sun from the west, and the earthly signs are the major signs, some of them like
the beads of a rosary;
if it breaks, some of them fall after others. He, may God bless him and grant him peace,
said: Chapter:
Whoever loves to meet God, God loves to meet him. The Imam, may God have mercy on him, mentioned the hadith of Ubadah ibn al-Samit on the authority of the Prophet, may God bless him and grant him peace, who said: Whoever loves to meet God, God loves to meet him. Whoever dislikes to meet God, God dislikes to meet him. May God have mercy on Ubadah, may God bless him and grant him peace.
Aisha or one of his wives said: We dislike death. He
said: It is not that,
but
when death approaches the believer, he is given glad tidings of God's pleasure and His honor, so there is nothing more
beloved to him.  What is before him, so he loves to meet
God and God loves to meet him.
Aisha, may God be pleased with her,
said: God, may God bless him and grant him peace, said: When the time of death approaches, the blessings of God are going to be bestowed upon him, and the blessings of God, and so at that time there is nothing more hateful to
him than what is before him, and he loves to meet God, and God, the Exalted and Majestic, said: And the disbeliever, when death approaches, is given glad tidings of God's punishment and retribution, and there is nothing more hateful to him than what is before him. He hates to meet
God and God hates to meet him.
[Music]
God, the Exalted and Majestic, and so on.
God, the Exalted and Majestic, and so on. So the
Prophet, may God bless him and grant him peace, explained here what the
meaning of the believer's love to meet God is when he is
dying and
sees the glad tidings. He
loves to meet God, and it is not that he hates death.
God, may God bless him and grant him peace, God, the Exalted and Majestic,
God, the Exalted and Majestic, and so on. And
Abu Ubaid al-Qasim ibn Sallam also explained a side to
the meaning of the hadith. He
said: Its meaning, in my view, is not the hatred of death and
its severity, for the
hatred of meeting God does not mean the
hatred of death.
Ubaidullah ibn Qasim al-Salam
said: This is a hadith
because this is something that almost no one is free from. Everyone
hates death,
but what is blameworthy
is  Preferring this world and
clinging to it, and hating to return
to God and the
Hereafter because of his known shortcomings,
is
presid
[music]
those who do not hope to meet Us and are content with this worldly life and are attached to it.
God Almighty
[music]
In this hadith, among the benefits is also the indication of
the principle that the reward is of the same kind as the deed, the
attribute of love for God Almighty, and consequently,
preparation for the
Hereafter. And
mentioning the hadith of Abu Musa on the authority of the Prophet, may God bless him and grant him peace, who
said: God Almighty said:
Abu Musa, may God be pleased with him,
said: Whoever loves to meet God, God loves to meet him, and whoever hates to meet God, God hates to meet him. And mentioning the hadith of Aisha, may God be pleased with her, who said: The
Messenger of God, may God bless him and grant him peace, used to
say, while he was
healthy,
meaning not in a state of illness, may God bless him and grant him peace
[music]: No prophet is ever
taken until he sees his place in
Paradise, then he is given a choice
[music]
[music].
When death came upon him, meaning his head was on his thigh, he was feared for
an hour, then he recovered and looked  His gaze was raised to the ceiling,
meaning he raised his gaze to the ceiling, then he said, "O
Allah, the Highest Companion." He said, "
Then he will not choose us," and
I know this is what he was talking about. She said, "And that was the
last thing the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, said: 'O Allah, the Highest Companion.'"
Read in Arabic:
The evidence from this hadith is that the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, was given a choice, so he said, "O Allah, the Highest Companion." So the evidence from it
in this chapter is that the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon
him, loved to meet Allah and chose Him.
Yes,
the hadith of
Allah, peace and blessings be upon him, is the Highest Companion. The hadith of Allah, the Exalted, is the
Highest Companion.
In this hadith is the greatest admonition,
which is the death of the Messenger of Allah, peace and blessings be upon him.
Chapter: The Agony of Death.
Imam Bukhari, may Allah have mercy on him,
mentioned the hadith of Aisha, may Allah be pleased with her, that she used to
say that the Messenger of Allah, peace and blessings be upon him, had a
small container
or a box of water in front of him. He would put his
hands in the
water.  He wiped his face with them and
said, "There is no god but Allah. Indeed, death has its agony. There is
no god but Allah, the
Exalted."
Then he raised his hand and began saying, "In the highest company,"
until he passed away and his hand fell limp.
He mentioned the saying of al-Bukhari, or al-Bukhari said after that, "The
box," meaning the water jug. The box is made of wood, and the water jug ​​is made of leather. Leather is the skin. He
distinguishes
between the box and the
water jug. The box is made of wood, and the water jug ​​is made of leather.
Before al-Bukhari, may Allah have mercy on him,
the box,
the water jug, the box.
I am not the agony of death.
It is what comes before death, the fainting and
the pain that accompanies
death and precedes it.
This hadith indicates that the severity of death does
not indicate a decrease in rank,
but rather for the believer it is
either an increase in his good deeds or an expiation of his sins.
From a sheikh of you.
[Music]
Also, this contains proof of the Exaltedness of the Almighty. Then he raised his
hand and said, "In the highest company,"
[Music]
Allah, the Exalted. May Allah's peace and blessings be upon him.
Also, this hadith indicates the humanity of the Prophet, may Allah's peace and blessings be upon him, and the prohibition of exaggeration. May
Allah's peace and blessings be
upon him.
He mentioned a hadith  Aisha also said that some Bedouin men, who were harsh and
rude, would
come to the Prophet (peace and blessings be upon him) and
ask him when the Hour would come.
He would look at the youngest among them and say, "
This one will live long enough to reach old age before the Hour comes upon
you."
Hisham ibn Urwah said, "Here, meaning their death." The
Hour is of two kinds: the Hour of the Day of Resurrection,
and the lesser Hour, which is the death of everyone. When a
person dies, their Hour comes.
These men used to ask the Messenger of God, "When will the Hour
come?" He
replied, "When this young one among you grows
old, your Hour will come." He meant that even though he is growing old now, you will have already
passed
60 and reached death.
This is the obligation, which is to emphasize the importance of
good deeds before death. He also
mentioned the hadith of Abu Qatada, who said that the
Messenger of God (peace and blessings be upon him) passed by him,
or passed by him, at the funeral of
Imam Bukhari (may God have mercy on him).
Qatadah, may
God bless him
and grant him peace, said: “He is at rest, and others are at rest from him, may God bless him
and grant him peace.” They said: “O Messenger of God, what is the one at rest and what is the one at rest from whom
others are at rest?”
[Music] The believing servant finds rest from the toil and harm of this world in the mercy of God, and the wicked servant is one from whom people, lands, trees, and medicine find rest. [Music] And to [Music] And the wicked one
here could be the disbeliever, the
beginner, or the sinner, all of them are included in this
category. [
Music] This is that the servants are divided into two categories: the people of faith and obedience, these find rest because they have turned towards reward and the mercy of God. As for the wicked one, people and lands find rest from him. God, the Exalted, and the Sublime. [Music] So
all the servants will experience the agony of death, but for the
believer it will be a reward,
expiation, and elevation, and for the wicked it will be a punishment.
This is the one who truly finds rest. The one who finds
rest is the one whom God Almighty forgives.
Therefore, some people err
when they see someone suffering from pain and illness, and the
illness lasts a long time until they die, and they say, "He has found rest."
[Music]
Because this is from the knowledge of the unseen. We only see the good and
fear for the bad.
[Music]
Imam Ahmad narrated on the authority of Aisha
that it was
said to the Messenger of God, "So-and-so has died and found rest."
The Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him,
said, after becoming angry, "Only he who has been forgiven by God finds rest."
Aisha, may God be pleased with her, Imam Ahmad
said, "God, may God bless him and grant him peace, has forgiven him." Then he mentioned the hadith of Abu Qatada on the authority of the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, who said, "The believer finds rest, and others find rest from him."
[Music] And
he mentioned the hadith of Anas, who said, "The Messenger of God said, 'Three things follow the deceased: his family, his wealth, and his deeds. His family and wealth follow him, and
his deeds remain.'"
The Imam, may God have mercy on him, narrated the hadith of Anas bin Malik, may God be pleased with him, peace and blessings be upon him.
This also indicates that the
servant must
prepare to meet God and do what will benefit him
in his afterlife, in his grave.  Striving in righteous deeds
[music] and
mentioning the hadith of Ibn Umar, may God bless him and grant him peace, who
said: “When one of you dies, his place is shown to him
morning and evening, either Hell
or Paradise. It is said, ‘This is your place
until you are resurrected to it.’” The
Imam, may God have mercy on him,
Ibn Umar, may God be pleased with them both, may God bless him and grant him peace, said: “This is your place until you are resurrected to it.”
This indicates the affirmation of the torment and bliss of the grave, and
that the grave is either a pit of Hellfire or it
means a
gate of Paradise or a garden of Paradise.
Also, the people of Paradise come to it and see their place, and they experience its fragrance,
scent, and pleasantness. As for the people of Hellfire, they experience its
poison and heat.
[music] The
believer’s place, as mentioned in the hadith of Abu Darda, is that
the believer in this state, when he sees his place and his location
in Paradise, says, “My Lord, hasten the Hour.” The
wicked one says, and the disbeliever says, “My Lord, do not hasten
the Hour,” because he knows that what comes after the grave is greater
torment, while the believer knows that what comes after the grave is greater
bliss.
[music]
Mentioning the hadith  Aisha (may Allah be pleased with her) said: The
Prophet (peace and blessings be upon him) said, “Do not revile
the dead, for
they have reached what they have sent forth.” Imam
Bukhari (may Allah have mercy on him) mentioned this hadith in the Book of Funerals and said, “Chapter on what is prohibited regarding reviling the dead.” This
hadith, “What is prohibited regarding reviling the dead,”
indicates that some forms of reviling the dead are prohibited, while others are
not, such as warning against them, mentioning
their faults, and pointing out their misguidance and
deviation.
This is also supported by what was narrated in the hadith of Anas: that he
passed by a funeral procession and people praised the deceased, so he said, “It is confirmed.” He passed by
another funeral procession and people spoke ill of the deceased, so they said, “It is confirmed,”
or he said, “It is confirmed,” and he did not rebuke them. Therefore, reviling the dead is not absolutely prohibited.
This is what the people of innovation use as evidence against the people of the Sunnah. Rather,
many who have passed away are unknown to us except because of the warnings of the
scholars against them and the explanation of the
Shaykh of Allah (may Allah be pleased with him). [Regarding the hadith about the deceased], she said
that this
proves here that not every single instance of reviling the dead is
impermissible; it relates to  the dead
right because there is that spe that
some of it is prohibited as it relates
to the dead some of it is not prohibited
such as the spe against the people of
innovation inarification of their
misgidance and for this we have the
proof which is the had of where he passed by
and he began to praise the individual
and he passed another
[music]
Chapter on the blowing of the trumpet. Mujahid said: The trumpet is like the shape of a horn, its sound is a blast.
Ibn Abbas said: The trumpet is the trumpet, and the quaking is the
first blast, and the following is the second blast.
That Imam Bukhari, may God have mercy on him,
Mujahid [
music] I
have a blast.
Ibn Abbas said:
The trumpet or the trumpet
[music] The
quaking is the trumpet, and
blowing it is included in belief in the Last Day. The trumpet is like the shape of a horn. And
it came in the hadiths that it is a horn that is blown, and the
Prophet, may God’s prayers and peace be upon him, came and said:
How can I be at ease when
the owner of the horn has put the horn to his lips and lowered his forehead and
is waiting for permission to blow it, so he blows. The
hadith of God, may God’s prayers and peace be upon him.
So
the Muslims said:
How do we say, O Messenger of God?   He
said, "Say, 'Sufficient for us is Allah, and [He is] the best Disposer of affairs.
We have put our trust in Allah, our Lord. Sufficient for us is Allah, and [He is] the best Disposer of affairs. Allah, the Exalted and Majestic, is Allah, and [He is] the best Disposer of affairs. We have put our trust in Allah, our Lord.'"
This indicates
that whoever hears such hadiths is
obligated to reflect upon them, return to his Lord, and seek refuge in Allah, his Master. It is
not merely a matter of information
to be memorized, but rather an impact on the servant's behavior,
his faith, strengthening his obedience, and his return to Allah, the Exalted and
Majestic.
Yes, Sheikh Munjin, may Allah preserve him,
and take as
for that type of narrations is
a must upon him. They have a heart that suffices his heart and back. Do not take upon him, they have a heart. Also, the words of Al-Bukhari, may Allah have mercy on him, indicate that there are two blasts, and this is the opinion of most scholars, may Allah have mercy on him. This is indicated by what came in the hadith of the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, that what is
between the two blasts is the hadith of
Allah, peace and blessings be upon him.
He mentioned the hadith of Abu Hurairah, who
said, "Two men were arguing, a Muslim and a
Jew. The Muslim
said, 'By the One Who chose Muhammad over all the
worlds!' The
Jew said, 'By the One Who chose Moses over all the worlds!' So the Muslim became
angry and slapped the face of the Jew." The
son of the Imam  May God have mercy
on Abu Hurairah, may God be pleased with him, peace and blessings be upon him.
All people
said by him, peace be upon him. So
the Jew went to the Messenger of God, peace and blessings be upon him, and
told him what had happened between him and the Muslim. The
Messenger of God, peace and blessings be upon him, said, “Do not
give me preference over Moses, peace be upon him,
for people will faint on the Day of Resurrection, and I will be among the
first to recover. Then I will see Moses grasping
the side of the Throne, meaning standing. I do not know whether Moses was among those who fainted and recovered
before me, or whether he was among those whom God, peace and blessings be upon him, excluded, until His saying, may He be exalted, ‘And the Trumpet will be blown, and all who are
in
the heavens and all who are on the earth will faint, except whom God wills.’ This is a
hadith of
God, may He be glorified and exalted, and
this contains an explanation of the virtue of Moses, peace be upon him, and his saying, ‘
Do not give me preference over
Moses,’
and also his saying, peace and blessings be upon him, ‘Do not give preference to one prophet over another.’ The
scholars answered this with a number of answers, peace and blessings be upon him, peace be upon him, peace be upon him, peace be upon him, peace be upon him,
meaning that with the saying of the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, ‘
I am the master of the children of Adam.’”  And there is no boasting in this scattered matter,
for the best of the prophets and our Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him,
[music]
that is also mentioned in another hadith that does not say that a servant is better
than Jonah, son of Matta, peace be upon him.
Ibn Kathir, may God have mercy on him, mentioned four answers to them,
many, may God have mercy on him. The
first answer is that the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him,
said it and he did not know its meaning before revelation was sent down to him. He
said, may
God have mercy on him,
[music] and the
second answer is that the lack of choice and the lack of
superiority, if it is in the form of fanaticism
and belittling the other, then this is not permissible among the
prophets. They are all good, but they differ in,
as happened in this hadith.
Yes, may
God have mercy on him, many
[music]
[music] and
the third aspect is that the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him,
said it out of humility, otherwise he is the master and guide of God, peace and blessings be upon him. The
fourth answer is
that the preference is not for you
[music]
but rather for God, the Exalted, the Almighty. He is the one who
prefers between His servants, and He informed that our master is the master of
creation,
God, the Mighty and Majestic.
[music]
In this hadith also, the justice of the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, his justice, peace and blessings be upon him,
mentioned the hadith of Abu Hurairah, the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him  May God’s prayers and peace be upon him. He
said, “People will faint when they faint, and I will be the first to rise
when Moses takes hold of the Throne. I do not know if he will be
in a state of standing.”
Imam Bukhari, may God have mercy on him, Abu Hurairah, may God be pleased with him, may God’s prayers and peace be upon him,
unconscious
and
not upon him
[music]. He
said, “Chapter or chapter: God will seize the earth on the Day of
Resurrection.”
The Imam, may God have mercy on him, may
God Almighty,
mentioned the hadith of Abu Hurairah that the Prophet, may God’s prayers and peace be upon him,
said, “God will seize the earth and fold the
heavens with His right hand, then He will say, ‘I am the King. Where are the kings of
the earth?’” May God be
pleased with him, may God’s prayers and peace be upon him.
This contains proof of the greatness of God Almighty, may He be glorified and exalted.
This greatness, the seizing of the
earth, and the folding of the heavens all engender fear of God
Almighty, may He be glorified and exalted. And
likewise, it contains proof of the attribute of the hands of
God Almighty, and that they are two real hands of
God Almighty.
What indicates the reality of the attribute is that these two hands were described with the attribute of
seizing and folding. He seizes and folds,
and these attributes do not exist because of what
the Ash'arites and others interpreted, that the hand means power, and
its meaning  The blessing cannot be that God seizes
the earth, or that seizing and folding are attributes of power,
or that seizing and folding are attributes of blessing. This can
only be with the two real hands. There is nothing
like Him, and He is the All-Hearing, the All-Seeing. May
God, the Exalted, hasten and follow. [
Music]
Hadith of Abu Saeed al-Khudri: The
Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, said: The earth will be
one loaf of bread on the Day of Resurrection, which the Almighty will fold with His
hand, meaning the Almighty will fold it with His hand as one
of you folds his bread while traveling. The descent of the people of Paradise.
Imam, may God have mercy on him,
Abu Saeed al-Khudri, may God be pleased with him.
God, peace and blessings be upon him.
God, as He, the Exalted, said: "On the Day when the earth will be changed to another earth, and the heavens as well." God, the Almighty, the Majestic,
said: [Music] A man from the Jews came and said: May the Most Merciful bless
you, O Abu al-Qasim. I tell you about the descent of the people of Paradise
on the Day of Resurrection. He said: Yes. He said: The earth will be one loaf of bread,
as the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, said. God, the Almighty, the
Majestic, bless
[Music]
God, peace and blessings be upon him. Then the
Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, looked at us and
laughed until his molars were visible, meaning with what was agreed upon.
He, peace and blessings be upon him, said this
Jew, peace and blessings be upon him, said
[music] He
said to him, he said, I will
not tell you their food. He said, their food is with the letters 'lam' and 'nun'.
He said, what is this? He said, a bull and a fish. They eat
from the excess of their livers. 70,000 people [music] said that will [music] people what is that said
[music] The hadith is what bread and meat are eaten with, and the name of the bull is from the words, its meaning is bull [music] hadith [music] The
garment, the fish is the
whale
[music]
hadith. And
this is the food of the people of Paradise
for the 7,000 who enter without reckoning or
punishment. The first thing that happens when these people enter is that
God Almighty honors them, that they are
His guests. The
first thing He honors them is that He
slaughters for them the bull of Paradise and
that they eat
the fish.
He specified the excess of its liver,
a piece
attached to the liver, which is among the most delicious things eaten from the
liver.
7,000
people
are
God
and also this fish. He specified also
they will have the excess of its liver. This is from the. It was narrated
on the authority of Abdullah bin Salam
that the first food that the people of Paradise eat is the excess of the liver of the enemy,
Abdullah.  Ibn Salam
said, and in the hadith of Thawban,
the people of Paradise will be given an extra portion of the liver of the whale. It is the whale that they will be given as the
first thing they eat. [
Music]
And in the hadith, it says
they will eat the whale first, and then their food will be slaughtered for them, and the
bull of Paradise, which eats from
its edges, will be slaughtered for them.
Yes.
[Music] May
God make us, you, our parents, and our sheikhs among the
people of Paradise.
Then he mentioned the hadith of Sahl ibn Sa'd that the Prophet, peace and
blessings be upon him, said, "The people will be gathered on the Day of
Resurrection on a white, dusty land, like a pure, clear disc, with no
landmarks for anyone." Dusty means white. The one who sets up the white one is the Imam, may God have mercy on him, Sahl ibn Sa'd, may God be pleased with him, peace and blessings be upon him. The meaning is that it has no landmarks, no signs of habitation, no buildings, and nothing of the landmarks by which one is guided
on the roads, such as mountains, rocks, and so on.
This is as God Almighty said, "On the Day when the earth will be changed to another
earth."
[Music]
And the scholars differed as to
whether the earth itself will be changed or whether it will be the same earth
but its characteristics will be changed, according to two opinions of the predecessors, may God Almighty be glorified and exalted.
He said, "Chapter: How will the gathering be?" May
God have mercy on him, and
he mentioned the hadith of Abu  Abu Hurairah (may Allah be pleased with him) narrated that the
Prophet (peace and blessings be upon him) said: “People will be gathered
in three groups:
two on a camel, three
on a camel, four on a camel, or ten on a camel. The
rest of them will be gathered by the Fire, which will stay with them
wherever they go, spend the night with them wherever they spend the night, and be with them wherever they go in the morning and evening with them wherever they go in the evening.” The Imam (may Allah have mercy on him) Abu Hurairah (may Allah be pleased with him) said: “The people will be gathered in three groups: two on a camel, three on a camel, four on a camel, or ten on a camel. The rest of them will be gathered
by the Fire, which will
stay with them wherever they go in the afternoon and spend the
night with them, and be with them in the morning and evening with them wherever they go in the evening.”
It has been mentioned that the gathering mentioned in the texts is of four
types. The
first gathering is the gathering of the Jews,
which is in the verse: “And He who
expelled the disbelievers among the People of the Scripture from
their homes…”  The first gathering
[music]
God, the
second fire that comes out of Aden
and walks with the people until it gathers them in the Levant. This is one
of the signs of the Hour.
This fire, as mentioned in the hadith,
walks with the people, rests, spends the night with them, and they are on the
road, gathering them and gathering them to the land of the gathering, which is the
Levant.
[music]
The third is the gathering of the people after the resurrection, and
We gathered them and did not leave out any of them. The fourth
[music] is the
gathering of the people to Paradise or to Hell.
Then he mentioned the hadith of Anas that a man said, “O Prophet of God,
how will the disbeliever be gathered on his face?”
He said, "Is He Who made him walk on his feet in this
world not
able to make him walk on his face on the Day of Resurrection?" Qatadah
said, "Yes, by the might of your Lord."
Imam Anas ibn Malik, may
God be pleased with him, said, "
God and the disbeliever,
face of
God, peace and blessings be upon him."
[Music] So,
walking here in this hadith in the verses is in its
true and apparent sense,
but in this world they
walk on their feet, but in the Hereafter they will walk on their faces as a humiliation and disgrace for
them. He will be dragged on his face
because he did not prostrate to God
and place his face on the
ground for God. In this
world, God punished him by making him be dragged on his face and
walk on his face on the Day of Resurrection to Hell.
[Music]
Hadith:
A walking up,
so here you find a person, he walks upon his legs,
however, some of the people here are going to walk upon their faces, and this is their Isra. Why? Because they did not prostrate to God and place their foreheads upon the ground, their faces upon the ground.
God Almighty, and this is like His
saying, "Those who are gathered on their faces
to Hell," and His saying, "And We will gather them on the Day of Resurrection on their faces,
blind and dumb." And
God Almighty said, "And We will
gather them on the Day of Resurrection on their faces."
Hadith of Ibn  Abbas says that you will meet God. The
Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, said that you will meet
God barefoot, naked, and uncircumcised, just
as God Almighty created you. May God have
mercy on Ibn Abbas, may God be pleased with them both.
[Music]
This is a sheikh,
meaning, and it
was also narrated from Ibn Abbas that he said, "I heard the Messenger of God, peace and blessings be upon him, giving a sermon
on the pulpit, saying, 'You
will meet God barefoot, naked, and uncircumcised.'" Meaning, prepare yourselves for what he says, "You will meet
God," meaning, prepare yourselves to
meet God Almighty. Prepare yourselves for what will happen
after the Resurrection. [
Music]
Ibn Abbas, may God be pleased with them both. Peace and blessings be upon him.
God Almighty. [Music]
[Music]
The hadith of Ibn Abbas is
also similar, but it has details.
He said, "The Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, stood among us giving a sermon
and said, 'You will be gathered barefoot, naked, and uncircumcised,
just as We began the first creation, We will repeat it.'"
Ibn Abbas, may God be pleased with them both.
[Music]
[Applause]
God, peace and blessings be upon
him.
[Music] And the first of creation to be clothed on the Day of Resurrection will be Abraham. This contains the virtue of Abraham, peace and blessings be upon him. [Music]
Abraham  Peace be upon
Abraham,
and he will be confronted with men from my nation, and they
will be taken to the left, that is, to Hell.
[Music]
I will say, "My Lord, my companions!" He
will say, "You do not know what they did after you." The intended
meaning of "my companions" here is my nation, from the general body of the nation, those who
came after him, as he said at the beginning of the
hadith, "They came with men from my nation."
These are the ones who committed apostasy. He does not mean the companions of the
Messenger of God. The companions of the Messenger of God are enemies, as testified by
the Quran and Sunnah. The companions of the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him,
God Almighty said, "I will say
as the righteous servant said, 'I was a witness over them as long as I
was in it,'" until his saying, "the Wise," meaning Jesus, peace be upon him.
Jesus, peace and blessings be upon him, the
Wise,
said, "It will be said that they continued to apostatize, and
this is their punishment." This includes the punishment of those who apostatize and the
punishment of those who innovate. Among the punishments of the people of innovation is that they will be driven away from the Prophet's Basin, peace and blessings be upon him,
as will also come
in other hadiths.
[Music]
Love of God
Introduced into.
And it also came in the hadith of Aisha, she said, "The Messenger of
God said, 'You will be gathered barefoot, naked, and destitute.'"  Peace and
blessings be
upon him. The hadith of Aisha, may God be pleased with her, may God bless her and grant her peace,
states: Aisha said, "O Messenger of God, men
and women will be looking at one another." He said, "The matter is more serious than that." Aisha, may God be pleased with her, said, "
God bless her
and Aisha, for the Day of Resurrection is a great day, a severe sermon. People, fear your Lord, for the earthquake of the Hour is a tremendous thing. On the Day when every nursing mother will be distracted from that which she was nursing, on the Day when a man will flee from his brother." And so on. [Music] God Almighty [Music] And this is evidence of Aisha's virtue, her modesty, her extreme chastity, and
her purity, not as the Rafidites say in their
slander against her in the land of the Messenger of God, may God bless him and grant him peace.
[Music]
Aisha. And
he mentioned the hadith of
Amr ibn Maymun on the authority of Abdullah, who said, "We were with the
Prophet, may God bless him and grant him peace, in a tent, and he said, 'Are
you pleased to be a quarter of the people of Paradise?' We said, '
Yes.'
And
he brings narration. Abdullah on the authority of who said we were in the tent. He said, 'Are
you pleased to be half of the people of Paradise?' We said, 'Yes.' He
said, 'By the One with the soul of Muhammad...'"  By His hand, I hope that you will be
half of the people of Paradise, peace and blessings be upon him.
This is a great glad tiding for the people of Islam and for this
nation, in demonstrating the superiority of this nation over other
nations.
[Music]
Muhammad, peace and blessings be upon him,
said: “Paradise will not be entered except by a
Muslim soul.
And you among the polytheists are but like a white hair
on the hide of a black bull, or like a black hair on the hide of a red
bull.”
This demonstrates the scarcity of the people of faith, and that even if you obey
most of those on earth, the path of God will still guide you.
Shaykh al-Islam Ibn Taymiyyah, may God have mercy on him, said: “
Likewise, the people of the Sunnah
are like a
white hair
on a black bull.” Meaning, among the people of innovation, the
people of the Sunnah are also few. This is
from Shaykh al-Islam Ibn Taymiyyah, may God Almighty have mercy on him.
He mentioned the hadith of Abu Hurayrah, may God Almighty be pleased with him,
which we will discuss later, that the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him,
said: “The first to be called on the Day of Resurrection will be Adam. Then
his offspring will be shown. It will be said: ‘This is
your father Adam.’ He will say: ‘At Your service, my Lord.’” The
Imam, may God Almighty have mercy on him, said: “The hadith of Abu Hurayrah, may
God be pleased with him, the hadith of
God, peace and blessings be upon him,
says: ‘Bring forth the contingent of Hell from your offspring, the contingent of the Fire.’”
Distinguish for us the people of Hell from others.
O Allah, take off their hands. Say, "O Lord, how many will be brought out?" He says, "Bring out 99 out of every 100." It is mentioned in another narration that among these 99 are Gog and Magog, due to their large number. They said, "O Messenger of Allah, if 99 out of every 100 are taken from us, what will remain of us?" So the
Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, gave them glad tidings that this
nation is small and the people of disbelief are many. So, a sign of the
salvation of this nation is that my nation among the nations is like the
white spot on a black bull. Peace be upon him.
[Music]
We also take the next chapter and the same
hadith, the chapter on the saying of Allah, the Exalted and Majestic, that the earthquake of the
Hour is a great thing. The Hour has drawn near, the Hour has drawn near,
all of it is about the nearness of the Day of Resurrection and the greatness of its horrors. May Allah, the Exalted, live and follow. May
Allah, the Exalted, follow,
meaning a supplication.
Then he mentioned the hadith of Abu Saeed, which combines the
previous hadiths, the
hadith of Abu Saeed, may
Allah be pleased with him,
that the Messenger of Allah, peace and blessings be upon him, said, "
Allah says, 'O Adam,' and he says, 'At Your service, and all goodness is
in Your hands.' He said, '
Bring out the contingent of Hell.' He said, 'And what?'"
The fire was sent, he said, “From every 900
and 99,
God, may God
bless him and grant him peace, O God, here I am at Your service and at Your pleasure, O
God, upon him
[music].”
He said, “That is when the young will grow old and every pregnant woman will deliver her burden, and you will see people as if they are drunk, but they are not drunk, but the punishment of God is severe [music].” He hastened, and that was difficult for them, that was hard on the Companions, and they were overcome with gloom and sadness. This is evidence of the Companions’ eagerness for salvation on the Day of Resurrection. They said, “O Messenger of God, where is that man, may God bless him and grant him peace?” He said, “
Rejoice, for from Gog and Magog there are a thousand, and from you there is one man, may
God bless him and grant him peace [music],” meaning from among the Muslims, from among you, from among the Muslims. Then he said, “By Him in Whose Hand is my soul, I hope that you will be a third of the people of Paradise.” He said, “So we praised God and
magnified Him.” Then he said, “By Him in Whose Hand is my soul, I hope that you will
be half of the people of Paradise. Your example among
the nations is like a white hair on the hide of a
black bull or a mark
on the arm of a donkey, may God bless him and grant him peace.”
This is also one of its benefits,
that when a servant is given good news, he magnifies God.  And
praise be to Him.
We will take the hadith that follows.
God knows best. May God’s prayers and peace be upon our Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him.